no take off the hat
handsome man
no reason to hide behind that
hey how you doing Mark hey Tyrone all
right hey you know actually about how
people have relationships with other
people and I guess I got a a
relationship with pain
you know and
sometimes I think you know how when
people go back to that woman like man
why you keep going back to that girl why
you keep going around just keep me using
you I mean you keep going back because
he he like the pain you go through
so I guess I I guess I'm a sucker for
pain huh because I keep going back to
pain
I mean
I put myself in predicament just to
enhance pain
and and be honest with you
I thought I was I thought I was getting
getting better
but I as I I feel that I'm getting
better I feel like I get more
uncomfortable with myself
because
I enjoy pain
and
they got this song say I'm a sucker for
pain you know and I'm probably the
biggest sucker it is
and I don't know if I'm talking bad
about myself because
I'm so used to negativity I mean look
I've been standing up at this place for
nine months now I must have went by just
that quick
and it scared me because
I never stayed nowhere that long
I always
jeopardize myself
and it seemed like I'm still trying to
find ways to jeopardize myself put
myself in situations
that I don't understand so I still don't
understand myself
I mean nine months to went back
I mean that's kind of scary
so now I'm ready to run again
now why I'm so ready to run
because I'm the uncomfortability I need
to do some pain I mean look
I can't really see that good
you know I was riding the bike and I hit
a police car
because I'm looking I can't see I'm
thinking the police car over here but I
was right in front of my face
and and I guess I didn't do it when I
hit it he came out and went off on me
and and by him screaming at me and
everything I kind of like
felt like it was a little comfortable
for him screaming at me because I was so
used to it I missed it be honest with
you I missed somebody screaming at me
talking crazy to me
because I've been having so much peace
and and when you got when you got peace
I don't know what to do
because now when I got peace I'm
thinking too Goddamn much
now I get to focus on me now
when when when you induce pain
I ain't got to focus on myself because I
feel what I need to feel
and it scares me because I want to go
back
to that pain I want to go back to I'm
gonna be honest with you I want to go
back to Old Tyrone
oh yeah you're looking better yeah yeah
hey
I'm looking better but I don't feel
better
it seemed like something's still missing
man I still got a void
and that pain feel that void I don't
know where to fill it with
you're more at home on the streets on
the streets man
man look you should see you should see
my room man and I hate to say this
I gotta sit down there oh we're
everywhere in my room I come in my
Rogers throws it on the bed just like I
was in a tent
I came in the tent I used to just throw
stuff everywhere
and that's crazy
but crazy it's normal
that chaotic
that pain
they're trying to watch people
that's not focuses on me I do not like
to focus on myself to be honest with you
and that's the thing I do not like
focusing on myself because I get to look
at myself who want to look at themselves
and you're holding on to the past I
enjoy that [ __ ]
nine months to went back now now
I'm like damn
nothing like I don't know what to do
somebody said we'll just keep doing what
you're doing then if I keep doing what
I'm doing I'm still going to reduce the
pain I want that pain back
they had
now now I want to be a track star be
honest with you now I want to just run I
just want to come back and and just come
back down here but
I'm scared what people gonna say about
me
I don't want nobody to talk about me
because
I got you I got the image that you think
I'm doing all right
but I'm not doing all right man I'm not
I'm scared
I'm really scared
I mean a new year coming
my birthday coming second of January
I'll be 56 years old six years check
this out over half of a century
that seems like a long time
but I keep holding back holding on to
[ __ ] that happened way back in the day
so I I still don't want to grow up
because I had that pain when I was young
and I'm still holding on that pain I
enjoy that pain
I remember man when I was Kid
my mama stop hauling me one one day I
don't know I guess she I grew up too I
don't know
and one day she kind of screamed at me
and I laughed I said Mom I missed that I
miss you screaming and hollering at me
and she looked at me like I was crazy
because see
when you don't scream and holler at me
I don't feel like you love me
look I had a coach
he said I was a good basketball player
and he was at the he used to have to hit
on us and put the paddle on us to make
me play basketball for me to get down
get down with the gritty-gritty
I didn't do that unless you put pressure
on me unless you screamed at me unless
you put some type of pain on me then I
get out
like I was a
All-Star
I enjoyed people hollering at me
screaming at me
talking [ __ ] to me I mean
down on me
it seemed like it was just it's just a
part of my life man
nine months to went back
and and it's so quiet up there
I look around
they got a little table we can look
table we gonna smoke cigarettes that and
this and that you know that's kind of
like I ain't gonna say it's a bad table
but it's a table that everybody came
from Skid Row from we all kind of sit at
the table talk Jive to each other and I
go to that table and there's different
races that I feel comfortable with we
talking [ __ ] to each other but when I
leave it seems like I'm by myself again
I thought it was going to be I could be
in a room by yourself
big rope uh big a remote big screen TV
and all that stuff but damn man I got to
clean this goddamn room
now I got the
still
people uh uh I am until myself
but when I was down here I had to keep
no image I can be me
I didn't care how you thought about me
but now since you thinking of me a
certain way I want you to keep thinking
that way but at the same time I want the
cake and eat it too I want my pain
now I can't have both of them I can't
cause if you think I'm all right that
means in your mind I'm all right so I
want you to keep thinking like that but
then at the same time I want you to
inflexible pain on me so I can make you
so you can make me feel loved
I still want to feel loved
but be honest with you I don't even know
what love is
so love is pain to me
I enjoy pain
I mean
I put myself in predicaments
just so you can say something crazy to
me
and then I and I kind of smiled behind
that
because it's that void I still have and
I still need it
to feel that void
I don't know what else to feel the void
with
I'm still searching I'm tired of
searching
now I'm going to be 56
I ain't gonna live in another 56 years
to keep searching
so I might as well inflect the pain back
on me so I can just as they say live my
live my life comfortably
but up here where I'm at can't do that
hey uh they check your rooms on Friday
and be honest with you I didn't even
clean the room
so I know they're gonna say something
but that's what I want them to I want
them to say something but my casework
was so cool sometimes I hate you so
goddamn cool because oh your room is all
right and I look at it it's not a high
not when you're talking about I got to
clean it
but a couple days ago you tell me make
sure your room clean
you know what I'm saying no
I'm angled the angle is
I want my cake it either too I want pain
and and and I still want some I want you
to think that I'm all right at the same
time
because if I get kicked out too many
people gonna talk about me
but if I can stay up there and you can
talk [ __ ] with me and I can have that
cake and eat it too
maybe I can feel a bit better because
now I got I'm you feeling you helping me
feel that void
and at the same time I'm still looking
good to you
you know I mean I still want to look
good to you because if I look good to
you you're gonna stay away from me let
me oh he all right
where do you think this all comes from
the way your your parents treated you
the paid it has a long time ago from a
kid
a long time ago and
whoever boy whatever that pain feel that
for whatever board I'm supposed to have
then that pain-filled it then now it's
just a part of me
it's a part of me it's a part of life
for me
now and like you say as I'm looking to
get kicked out
unconsciously I just might be
I just might be
you know I I I I I I I died you
jeopardize yourself and and you know I
even know I did that I know I did that
subconsciously
so it was so I'm still fighting with
self you're going to settle into the
level of self-worth that you
subconsciously have but I still want
that cake and eat it too
you know what I'm saying so I still want
you to think I'm looking good that I'm
feeling all right so you only got to
approach me but at the same time I need
that void field
and that pain the pain is the only thing
you feel that void cause they've been
feeling it so long
add joint so am I sucker
because I keep going back to that woman
so when I keep going back to pain
but I enjoy it just like I hey if I went
kept going back to a relationship I had
and I know it's bad for me and I keep
going back to it I enjoyed then right so
if I enjoy it
what can you say
if I accept it you show them got to
accept it
because it's about me
because I want
I'm trying to make you I'm trying to
make myself feel good I ain't trying to
make you feel good I'm trying to make
myself feel good so if I make myself
feel good only way I can make myself
feel good if I go through this pain
and that pain has to stay up on me
I mean
life
I want some paper all right Joe when you
scream at me some goddamn time
yeah sometimes you know what I'm saying
when y'all come over there you be mad at
other people I'll be like damn well I do
there's a lot of [ __ ] outside that
door I mean man
I mean sometimes I wish y'all I was in
your queue you go through me like God
damn all this drama I'll be smiling at
you
because that should be looking fine
I don't like it I understand that but I
do I would like that [ __ ] because it's
drama
I enjoy that [ __ ] that [ __ ] makes me
smile man Skid Row skinny bro
I mean man that's
that's always down here
negativity and negativity come so normal
it's like a way of living it's a way of
life
what they say you you you could take
Oyster Water but you can't make them
drink it to the web and make them drink
it
the same with me
I mean you can't take me out of pain you
can't take me out of Skid Row
you took me out of scared robot I still
need to be Inskip Rover why I keep
coming back every day
there's one cat up there came from down
here from uh he said man I ain't going
back down there no more
he be trying to make me hey man you
wanna go to the store for me [ __ ] I'm
not gonna go to stole for you
if I leave I'm going downtown oh no I
ain't going down there why you ain't
going down there oh I told him when I
left man I told him captain Oh I'm gonna
leave him right down here with it
all right well I'm going back down there
where I was at
but I I
they said you can't live on both sides
of the streets I've been doing all right
because I go on that side of the street
then I come back down on this side of
the street so it's a day and night thing
just like living on both sides Street
day and night
now I know I ain't gonna keep on doing
it because
I'm gonna get tired so now I hope I
don't fall out
trying to live on both sides of the
street
like I said hey
I'm through with crack
but now I've been drinking a little bit
more you've had relationships with women
in your life that are I don't know man I
had a relationship with one woman man
she was a straight alcoholic
but when she became alcoholic she should
try to abuse me
hit on me and everything
you liked it you know
I kind of laughed at it because I
enjoyed her like that
you know what I'm saying because she was
the nicest nicest individual in the
world when she was drunk give me money
and everything
oh hey take this hold it listen that
but when she wasn't drunk she was ornery
you know what I'm saying
I mean
I enjoyed you trying to hit on me and
I'm like you know what I'm saying I used
to laugh
because that looked I felt that little
pain I felt that comfortability I felt
that when I was young again
helped me feel that void you know what
I'm saying I enjoyed that [ __ ] man
I enjoyed that paint I enjoyed that
trying to get physical hitting on me
I don't hit women
you know what I'm saying but I I had a
couple abusive relationships you know
what I'm saying and and I felt
comfortable with it but they hit you you
know what I'm saying but they hated me
because I didn't act the way they wanted
me to act
so how can you get mad because I acting
the way you want me that because you
showed them acting the way I want you to
act subconsciously because you feeling
that void I got I get it
and I didn't even know it
because when I when I when I leave from
a certain situation and I miss it I go
back to the situation
I think they're recreating what your
parents gave you from a long time ago
and it fills that void you know what I'm
saying and see that's funny for girl
treated you
sweetest pie sweet spot you know what
I'm saying you'd turn it down I turn it
I didn't want it yeah and everybody else
was coming around because she was
so nice but I stayed around when she got
drunk
because I enjoyed that [ __ ] I enjoyed
that pain she flicking on me trying to
be abusive
am I crazy
you're human I appreciate that you know
what I'm saying I really do appreciate
that
but they say
there's something wrong with you when
you know something wrong with you and
you don't do nothing about it
but am I since you say I'm normal and I
know something wrong with me
so
I know man ain't nothing wrong with me
because this is the way my that's the
way I live my life
it's normal to me so it can't be nothing
wrong with me during the club you know I
mean
well you might still gotta avoid in your
life somewhere I'm sure I do you know
but you don't let it take over your life
you probably got more
positive than your negative
no I think
you know the we get programmed
as young children
by the caregivers that we had the
parents or whoever was
around when we were six years old
and the the unconditional love or the
neglect or the abuse or whatever
traumatic experiences we went through
when we were young children
is what we'll seek out as adults
especially in romantic relationships
and uh
and we'll we'll find situations that'll
they'll recreate that or
give us an opportunity to maybe do it
differently next time with you know
maybe we can heal from that or something
but it seems like we seek out similar
situations to what we had as children
because you you put yourself yourself
you've been in situations to do that
only situation I've been in
pain
and that's what that's what I need to
put myself in to get back my
comfortability
man I couldn't deal with millions of
people like this because
only way I can deal with [ __ ] if I
know you if I've been around you but if
I don't know you I can't be around no
[ __ ] if I don't know you I need to
know you because I feel like you're my
circle
now if you're in my circle and I feel
like and you and I'm going through that
[ __ ] with you I'm all right because
I know you
cause you're part of me now
but if I don't know you you ain't a part
of me so now now now I'm pushing you
back
now I'm trying to put an image on you to
make you think I'm all right because I'm
not accepting you in my circle I'm not
accepting you you're doing my pain
because I don't know you I need to know
you to get some pain
because I knew you when I was a kid
I knew my coach my basketball coach when
I played ball
I knew the girl I was with because it
was a relationship
I got to know you induce the pain if I
don't know you I can't induce the pain
that's crazy man yeah that's crazy and
they said man is terrible thing to waste
I love the way I think I
whether I'm right or wrong it's valid it
works for you because it's the way I
think
it's for me it ain't for nobody else
it's for me
and you know what
I cried one day and I felt good crying
and I got to
rocking
because I ain't cried in so long
you know and I and I missed that
you know
being by myself just crying
you know
I enjoy that [ __ ] man
but
I need to know you
so I can so you can do some pain on me
man that's the only way I can feel
comfortable
I need that comfortability back
I need the back man
you know where I need it I need to
surround myself with people that induce
pain on me that I know
I don't need you around me if I don't
know you because I ain't gonna accept
your pain
that you're giving me I need to know you
to accept it
because if I don't know you I'ma run
from it
because it ain't comfortable to me
I need you to be a part of my life
I need somebody in my life to give me
let me go through some pain
and there's a pain in my life man
I need some pain in my life I miss it
I need you to be a part of my life
to endure the pain man
look
up
I'm busy that boy
I'm pleased you to help me see that boy
I think that boy feels about the way
[Music]
I feel like I'm by myself
man
the only way I got the stuff
if I feel like you're part of me
thank you
I got I need you a part of me for me to
go through something man
if I don't go through nothing and you're
gonna pardon me and then you're a part
of me
that's the only way you're gonna work
for me
and I need it man
I need it I need it I need it man
laughs
I guess you can't say I'm a sucker
sucker for pain because I enjoy it
you're not the only one
man
I've been missing a lot of things man it
seems like I can't
if I go through some pain I feel like I
can accomplish something
you know pay pay
baby made me do [ __ ]
maybe try to stress that maybe maybe we
want to work hard
maybe if you don't put me through no
pain
I don't feel like you're trying to help
me
pain and anger or rocket fuel
yeah
I miss you man
foreign
but I only want people
in my circle you give me the pain
I need I feel that you care
and I don't know if that works like that
they work for me
you know it's kind of
so so hey man I'm still trying to learn
I'm still searching I ain't trying to
put nobody else in my circle
but um the people that's in my circle
I don't see them no more so do I gotta
invit some people to put in my circle
the field day boy they feel my pain
because it's gonna be an ongoing process
because I ain't gonna stop till I get
that pain back
I appreciate you my man
I really appreciate you man
thank you man I appreciate y'all man let
me know huh
that's all right
thanks man
you're gonna be okay yeah
that's good